it's the first night of the take me home
tour Louie was unusually nervous so
remember earlier this year when the HBO
series euphoria caused an all-out uproar
when they portrayed Louie Tomlinson and
Harry Styles enjoying a steamy moment
together Eric can sense the nervous
tension running through Louie's stiff
body yeah well in a new interview with
The Guardian Louie admits he was mad
quote I know culturally it's interesting
but I'm just a bit tired of it
adding I'm not going to lie I was pissed
off it annoyed me that a big company
would get behind it okay let's rewind
shall we in euphoria's third episode the
character Kat Hernandez wrote a fan
fiction story about Larry Stylinson the
fictional couple named fans created for
fictional couple Louie and Harry what
made her famous was her story the first
night a 7,000 word fact that was largely
credited with starting the Larry
Stylinson conspiracy theory
the Harry Styles and Luis Olmos in of
one direction were secretly fun the
scene was animated and got hella graphic
Louie was unusually nervous his mouth
was dry palms sweating when suddenly he
felt the press of Harry's body from
behind but Harry what if someone sees
let them fans flock to social media like
bats out of hell to talk about the
episode and many of them wondered if
Harry or Louie gave their approval
beforehand Louie quickly answered that
question replying to a tweet from a fan
quote I can categorically say that I was
not contacted nor did I approve it ok so
that's what we call a hard no a month
after the episode aired Louie slammed a
tabloid article about he and Harry being
in a relationship tweeting that those
theories are the biggest load of bull
I've ever heard and in an interview with
the Sun in 2017 Louie explained that the
theories are a little bit disrespectful
to his girlfriend
Eleanor quote it created this atmosphere
between the two of us where everyone was
looking into everything we did it took
away the vibe you get off someone it
made everything I think on both fences a
little bit more unapproachable Barbie
Ferrara who plays cat in the HBO show
also spoke about the controversial scene
telling The Hollywood Reporter quote
when I first read the script that was
the first thing that popped out to me
because I can relate to that as a 22
year old woman who lived through the
onedirection age by the year's end she'd
become one of the most prolific smut
writers on tumblr she was known for her
au crossovers and her consistent nc-17
ratings of course euphoria has been
getting a major buzz for its intense
provocative storylines ET was at the
premiere chatting with the series stars
and deya about how she tackles those
challenging scenes
I think we all in this cast about to
push ourselves and be vulnerable and and
it's been hard and there's been fun days
and there's been really tough days but
I'm so lucky to be working with the
people that I'm working with I'm so
thankful for the warm
I think safe space that we've created on
set to be able to go to those places and
and yeah I'm just you know proud of it
all right so here's what we learned
today don't mess with lewy euphoria is
wild and zendaya is proud okay you can
count on et to keep you up to date on
all things wild in Hollywood so make
sure to keep it locked right here until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]